what's going on everyone alex from moza
here three companies who uh
now have done over 110 million dollars
in sales
and this video i want to talk about the
entrepreneurial journey as it relates to
control
and the reason i think this is so
important and this is probably the
biggest reason that people get stuck
all right and so at the end so what i'm
going to do here is i'm going to explain
kind of how control shifts throughout
the entrepreneurial journey
where people get stuck and at the very
end of the video i'll tell you
basically the the most valuable rule of
thumb that i've learned
in scaling our companies all right so
first thing is the reason
entrepreneurship is so difficult is
because it forces you to change
who you are your identity the values
that you supposedly have as you continue
to grow i'm not saying your
you know honesty etc those types of
values but the the way that you see the
world and how you operate
because in the very beginning you most
of us at some point have to transition
from
a lack of control to complete control
right and what i mean by that is
either you you know went straight into
entrepreneurship where you shifted
control from your parents to yourself
right or in many other instances you
started you had a job someone else was
kind of responsible for
your income for the most part because
they're paying you you weren't
generating it yourself
and so you're very limited right and
then you jump to taking complete
ownership
over all of your outcomes right and so
you have complete control
the difficult thing is is that the thing
that takes you the first step that huge
leap of saying i'm going to be
completely in control is usually the
thing that will stifle most
entrepreneurs who are trying to grow
right because if you have complete
control and complete ownership that's
great but
there's only one of you right and so
what what that leads to is kind of this
this buyback and i think the first time
i heard this recently was denmark tell
us talking about buyback principle and i
just like the
terminology but basically you just
continue to buy back
your time as you continue to grow the
company and so in the very beginning
most people are buying back support time
so it's just kind of like
lower skilled support tasks that they're
doing in their business so it's like
them and then they've got maybe an
assistant right
and then after that there might be
higher level support or administrative
tasks so that might be like
billing collections contracts all that
kind of stuff that might happen
in the business after you have like your
kind of support role
taken care of from there the next level
of control that people have to give up
is selling right no one can sell like me
no one gets it like i get it people just
don't relate to my customers right
and the issue is control you're trying
to control the whole thing
and the thing is is that every time you
add someone in and you buy back more of
your time you relinquish
control and so the thing is is that
every level of entrepreneurship i'm
telling you right now
it is always uncomfortable because the
thing that you are now holding on to is
the thing that you have to give up
and this has been one of the hardest
things for me a lot of this is because
we identify
with being the thing right in the
beginning i'll give you a
simple example because we work so many
gyms people be like no one treat
trains a class like i do right so that's
the first level of fulfillment right
first level of
of delivery is is training right it's
also the first thing they need to
outsource
and the reason for that is because the
market will pay someone 15 an hour
somebody will come in for 15
an hour to do that work well if you have
work that pays you a hundred dollars an
hour then you should be doing 100
an hour or not the 15 hour work but they
think because they like to feel special
they like to feel unique no one can
train like i can train
well i mean obviously there's probably
some people train a lot better than you
so maybe you should let them do the
training right and then after that
usually the business owner will do
contracts billing you know and they're
usually not that good at it anyways
because they're entrepreneurs
and so that's the next thing that
happens right and so then the next piece
might be
some sort of assistant of some kind or
some sort of right-hand operator that
would help you out
right and then again there it's like
well no i don't trust anyone with the
money
if i'm not looking at the money then
then we're gonna we're gonna lose
well i used to say the same thing until
i had someone who's better at tracking
the money than i am huh
crazy right and so i had to give up
control of the money i'm not saying i
don't look at it
right but i had to give up control of it
and so then i'm just selling
right because that's the highest value
thing i could do at the time was i could
just talk to people and get them to give
us money
right but then eventually there's too
many too many consultations that have to
happen i still have to run the business
right and so i have to give that control
over to someone else which is probably
one of the biggest
and most difficult people this is
usually either thing that gets in the
way of people going
i'd say from a million over so we're
doing over a million so
up to a million dollars a year you can
just sell yourself right like you
yourself can sell and you can have these
other people who are assisting you
but once you cross a million it's
usually difficult to be doing the
selling yourself
and that's where you have to start
scaling sales so you have to give that
control up
right the next level after control of
the sales
is now you have to teach other people
in a group not just one person but a
group of people how to sales you have to
manage a sales team you have to recruit
you have to hire you have to train
compensate etc and again that's levels
of control but again here here
even with the sales team you're talking
maybe three maybe 10 million
when you get to 10 million trying to go
to 30 the level of control that you're
giving up here
is leadership weird right
because there's too many departments too
many people you can't lead everyone
right so you have to lead a small group
of people and get them
to lead the people who are underneath of
them right and so again it's a level of
control it's control over your
your culture now obviously you want to
lead it you want to lead by example you
want to be the the most distilled down
version of that thing so that it
it permeates right but as you continue
to buy back
i think the question that i like to ask
myself is what am i what am i trying to
control
what am i trying to control and i think
if you think about that
and then rather what part of my identity
am i giving up
by giving up this control i used to
think i was you know such a great
salesman
right no one can sell like i can sell
but you know what i can't outsell 12
guys
right i i literally can't you know what
i mean i can't do it
and so and if the business model
requires you know only
a soup like your level of sales to to
make it work then the model's broken
right you should be able to have people
close half as many as you and still make
the model work
right now obviously over time you want
to get them to sell better than you
because all they're doing is selling
right whereas you were when you were
selling the way you did you were running
the business
and so with each each of this kind of
cycle is you have to give up control
and so i told you the beginning of the
video that i will
give you the rule of thumb that has been
served me very well
in running my companies which is how far
away do you get
right how far away do you get when you
when you relinquish control because the
thing is is you relinquish control but
you still take full accountability
and responsibility for the results
that's what's wild
is that you have to say i'm going to
give this over to you
i'm losing control and yet i'm still
responsible
that'll trip you up but the rule of
thumb that i use is know where the
bodies are buried
know where the bodies are buried and so
what i mean by that is
if i don't know where the flaws are
in a department i'm too far away
so if i'm if you know if i talk to let's
say a marketing director or i talk to a
sales director i talk to uh you know
customer support i talk to
you know finance and i don't know where
the bodies are buried like i don't know
what the issues are because every
department has issues
every department has problems it's a
business it's made of humans and humans
are imperfect
right which means that there are always
imperfections there are things that are
not working as well as they could
if i can't name problems if i don't know
where the bodies are buried in
the department then i'm too far away
right now when i say that doesn't mean i
have given up too much control that's
not the issue it's just i need more
transparency i need to be paying more
attention
to that area and this rule of thumb has
served me well so if i start hearing
only good news from a department and i
don't hear anything negative
i'm too far away and this has been my my
managerial leadership rule of thumb that
has really helped me a ton
is know where the bodies are buried and
so this is the entrepreneurial journey
in a nutshell i got a lot of feedback
from the zero to 100 million dollar
video that i made of kind of the steps
from a business model
perspective but from the personal
perspective the issue is control and
that's why most people can't get stuck
because they have all these personal
issues that prevent them
from controlling i'm sorry alex i just
don't trust people i have trust issues
well
get over it because you're not going to
build something great without trusting
other people
so if you want your mom or your dad or
the thing that you know you have your
trust issues with
to be the reason that you're not
successful but give them more power go
you know power to you right just get
just keep giving them control over your
life
because you have these issues right or
you can decide
i think this person's done enough damage
to me in my life
i'm not going to let them stop me from
accomplishing what i want
i want to accomplish and so i'm going to
take back that power i'm going to take
back the control over my outcomes
take responsibility which may feel
shitty in the moment because it means i
suck
but at least i suck and i don't point at
them saying they suck because i can
control what i do
and as a result i can go through this
process and continue to buy back
and relinquish control buyback and
relinquish control buyback and relay
cruise control
first of the doing then of the admin
then of the the ops then of the sales
and then of
having a sales team and then of the
leadership and then continuing on
and on as we relinquish more and more
control right
how can you be free if you control
everything interesting
anyways lots of love keeping awesome
i'll catch you guys on the flip side
hope you found this valuable
bye